chers amis,
merci de m'avoir invité à m'adresser à vous
aujourd'hui lors de la session plénière sur la
démocratie en Europe. J'apprécie votre
solidarité et votre engagement en faveur de la Biélorussie démocratique
la semaine dernière. J'ai parlé au
Parlement européen à Strasbourg de notre
choix européen.
J'ai dit que sans la Biélorussie en Ukraine,
la  Le projet européen ne sera pas
achevé et c'est ce que nous pensons que
nous voulons ramener la Biélorussie dans l'Europe à
laquelle elle appartient
la situation en Biélorussie reste sombre
Le festin de fer du régime a resserré
son emprise mon pays a été mangé morceau
par morceau
il est dévoré par  une énorme bête
aux ambitions impériales La Russie aidée par
un dictateur local avec un appétit
de pouvoir Alexander Lokashenka
l'ambition reflète les objectifs de la Russie en
Ukraine de transformer la Biélorussie en
une autre colonie civile
ont pris 9 millions de Bérusses en otage,
infligeant la terreur à quiconque
descend
systématiquement  anéantissant notre
société civile, les médias, la langue et la culture, les
répressions s'intensifient sans
cesse, il y a plus de 1 500
prisonniers politiques détenus dans des conditions humaines
le mois dernier, plus de 500 ont été détenus
pour avoir exprimé leur opinion et leur soutien à
l'Ukraine,
maintenant le régime tente d'étendre son pouvoir.
la répression au-delà de nos frontières les
tensions avec nos voisins la Pologne et la
Lituanie montrent les politiques imprévisibles et
dangereuses du
régime de Loukachanka qui affectent non seulement le
peuple barousien mais l'ensemble de
l'Europe
aujourd'hui. Loukachanka se venge des
Biélorusses exilés en refusant de renouveler leurs
passeports dans les missions diplomatiques
pour beaucoup, retourner en Biélorussie pour obtenir
un nouveau document légal n'est pas une option, cela
pourrait signifier un repos de torture ou pire, l'
Europe devrait donner à ces personnes un
statut légal afin qu'elles n'aient pas à mettre en péril
leur liberté en tombant dans un piège en
Biélorussie
nous sommes en train d'élaborer une
nouvelle version du passeport qui sera délivrée
par le cabinet de transition uni
confirmant que chaque titulaire est un
citoyen biélorusse très bientôt nous
produirons des spécimens et nous ferons ensuite
campagne pour la reconnaissance de ces
documents par les gouvernements nationaux nous
demanderai également à la France de reconnaître ce
document
et malgré tous ces défis auxquels nous sommes
confrontés notre regard reste fermement fixé sur
l'Europe notre histoire commune et nos
liens culturels nous rappellent que la Biélorussie 2 appartient à
cette communauté de Nations qui valorisent
la liberté et les droits de l'homme
Je vous demande de  soutenons nos
aspirations européennes en août nos
forces démocrates ont fait une déclaration commune
exprimant clairement notre choix européen notre
ambition est d'obtenir le statut de
candidat membre de l'Union européenne
nous devons nous débarrasser de la dictature
qui nous éloigne de l'Europe
permettez-moi de citer  notre lauréate du prix Nobel de la paix
Elizabeth, qui est aujourd'hui détenue comme
prisonnière politique, la
Biélorussie est à la croisée de l'
Histoire, où ira-t-elle dans 20 ans,
fera-t-elle partie de l'Empire russe
ou sera-t-elle un pays véritablement européen
et c'est ici que la France joue un rôle important
rôle central
La France est un pilier de la démocratie européenne une
nation dont l'esprit révolutionnaire a
inspiré d'innombrables autres est un
allié important dans les bâtisseurs et
la lutte pour la liberté
nous avons collaboré étroitement avec
Frederick PT à l'Assemblée nationale
et d'autres dédiés à notre parcours nos
efforts communs sont  non seulement pour le
présent, ce sont des investissements dans l'
avenir où les Biélorusses peuvent rêver, parler
et vivre librement,
mais le voyage à venir est long et difficile
à mesure que nous avançons vers une
Biélorussie démocratique, nous avons besoin que l'Europe soit à nos côtés,
nous demandons de reconnaître que la poursuite
de  la liberté en Biélorussie n'est pas seulement une
préoccupation régionale mais européenne
vous devez tenir Loukachenka et ses
acolytes responsables de leurs crimes
le dictateur doit être traduit devant le
Tribunal pour crimes contre l'humanité en
Biélorussie et crimes de guerre en Ukraine cela
nécessite une volonté politique et une volonté politique  un
précédent important pour d'autres dictateurs
dans le monde.
J'exhorte les représentants ici présents aujourd'hui à
reconnaître l'urgence de la situation
en Biélorussie, à vraiment prendre du recul
et à veiller à ce que les valeurs de démocratie, de
liberté et de droits de l'homme ne soient pas seulement
des idéaux consignés dans des documents, mais soient
ont vécu des parents proches pour chaque Européen,
y compris le peuple biélorusse
et je voudrais emprunter les
récompenses de Victor Gregor, il n'y a
rien de plus puissant qu'une idée dont le
moment est venu, l'idée d'une
Biélorussie démocratique est arrivée et avec la
volonté collective de l'Europe et la soutient
deviendra notre réalité commune merci